Let's now consider
our rolling wheel,
and we want to look at
some special conditions.
So at time t equals 0--
and we'll have our wheel that's
rolling, here's the ground--
let's say that our point P
is right up here at the top.
That's cm.
And we'll be in the
ground frame now.
And then at a
later time, time t,
the wheel has
moved to the right.
So let's draw the
wheel over here.
Not the greatest
picture of the wheel,
but we'll have the
wheel over here.
And now the point P has
moved some angle delta theta.
And we'll call this
time interval delta t.
Now, the center of mass of the
wheel has moved a distance.
Xcm is the velocity of the
center of mass times delta t.
And the point P on the
rim, this arc change,
this length here
on the rim that P
has moved around in the
center of mass frame,
is R delta theta.
Now, we want to ask ourselves--
we'll call this delta x.
We now have three
possible conditions.
We call rolling
without slipping.
That will be our first case 1.
And that's the case
when the arc length
delta s is exactly equal to
the distance along the ground.
So we have delta Xcm is delta s.
And so we get Vcm delta
t equals R delta theta,
or Vcm equals R delta
theta over delta t.
Now, in the limit as
delta t goes to 0,
we have that delta
theta over delta t
in this limit as delta t
goes to 0 is d theta dt
And that's what we
called the angular speed.
So in our limit as this wheel
is rolling without slipping,
we have the condition that the
velocity Vcm equals R omega.
So that's our first condition,
and we call this the rolling
without slipping.
Now what is Vcm?
Vcm?
That's the velocity of the
center of mass of the wheel,
and every single point on this
wheel has that same speed.
And R omega, you can think of
that as the tangential velocity
in reference frame cm.
This is just the speed
in the reference frame
moving with the center of mass.
So this is our condition for
rolling without slipping.
Now, our second case is
imagine that the wheel is not
moving forward at all,
but it's just spinning.
That's what we call the wheel
is slipping on the ground,
for instance, if there were ice.
And so what we call slipping
is a little bit more general.
It's whenever the
wheel is spinning,
and the arc length
is much greater
than the horizontal distance
that the wheel has moved.
So we have delta s
representing the arc length
that the point has
moved in the center
of mass frame is greater than
how far the center of mass
is moving.
And so, again, we have R delta
theta is greater than Vcm delta
t, or in the limit R
omega is greater than Vcm.
You can say it's spinning
faster than it's translating.
And finally, the
skidding condition.
Skidding-- imagine that the
wheel-- you're braking a wheel.
The wheel is not
spinning at all,
but it's just sliding
along horizontally.
So the horizontal
delta x center of mass
is bigger than delta scm.
And so this is the case where
delta Xcm, how far it moved
horizontally, is greater
than the amount of arc length
that the point moved.
And so in the same
type of argument,
when we put our conditions
in we get that Vcm
is greater than R omega.
And again, what that corresponds
to in the skidding case,
imagine the limit where
it's not rotating at all,
this would be 0, and it's just
skidding along the ground, Vcm.
So we have our three conditions.
We have the slipping
condition, where it's spinning
faster than it's translating.
We have the skidding
condition, where
it's translating faster
than it's spinning.
And we have the rolling
without slipping condition,
in which the arc
length is exactly
equal to the distance,
horizontal distance,
along the ground.